[Musik]
Bild breaking news
in der Tat in der Bild liegt ein
brisantes Papier aus dem
Finanzministerium vor vorhin in unsere
Hände gekommen dort ist die Rede von
neuen Finanzhilfen für die Messe und
Veranstaltungsbranche neue finanzhelfen
im Umkehrschluss brisant ist daran die
Begründung dann es besteht offenbar
weiterhin ein Ausfallrisiko für
Veranstaltungen in diesem Jahr begründet
wird das mit den hohen
corona-incidenzsaal genau das aber
sollte ja eigentlich nicht mehr der
alleinige Maßstab der corona-politik
sein bei uns ist Philipp piatov der
dieses Papier bekommen hat Philipp genau
ich habe das hier von meinen Kollegen
aus dem Politik Ressort erhalten wir
haben das wirklich gelesen und waren
schockiert ich kann es hier einmal in
die Kamera zeigen dass es hier dieser
Brief zwei Seiten und auf der zweiten
Seite da steht was was uns wirklich
massiv überrascht hat ich lese einmal
vor
und zwar will das Finanzministerium 150
Millionen Euro locker machen und
begründet das damit dass aufgrund der
aktuell wieder stark ansteigenden
Inzidenzen und der stagnierenden
Impfbereitschaft sowie dem Beginn der
kühleren Jahreszeit mit leichterer
virusverbreitung jetzt wird es wichtig
weiterhin ein großes Ausfallrisiko für
Messen und Ausstellung aufgrund Corona
bedingter Beschränkungen besteht das
heißt zusammengefasst ist droht wieder
im Herbst und Winter ein massiver
Ausfall von Großveranstaltungen und
messen und das Absurde ist das wird
wieder mit der mit dem Ansteigen der
Inzidenz gegründet
darauf kommt es nicht mehr an da waren
sich doch im Prinzip Philipp alle einig
haben gesagt wir müssen auch auf die
Hospitalisierungen blicken die Inzidenz
die hat schon lange ausgesorgt die taugt
nicht mehr als einziger wert nachdem man
Maßnahmen ausrichten kann absolut die
Inzidenz fliegt ja jetzt auch aus dem
Infektionsschutzgesetz es gibt kein
Minister der nicht einmal hoch und
heilig versprochen hat dass die Inzidenz
keine Rolle mehr spielen soll und jetzt
sollen wegen angeblich steigender
Inzidenzen Veranstaltung abgesagt werden
messen abgesagt werden dass es erstmal
ein riesiger Schock für die ganze
Branche die ihr seit Beginn der
coronakrise unglaublich gelitten hat das
ist ja mal das erste was abgesagt wird
sind messen und Großveranstaltungen
jetzt ging es ja gerade wieder los auch
mit der IAA man hatte Hoffnung dass es
jetzt auch weitergehen kann denn ein
Großteil der Menschen ist ja geimpft die
Krankenhäuser sind nicht wirklich mehr
belastet über und überhaupt nicht mehr
gefährdet also da gibt es kein Kollaps
der irgendwie bevorsteht wie kann es
sein dass das aus dem Finanzministerium
kommt offenbar ohne Rücksprache dann mit
den anderen beispielsweise
Gesundheitsministerium das kann ich mir
ehrlich gesagt schwer vorstellen also
offenbar scheint man in der
Bundesregierung heimlich dennoch an der
Inzidenz fest zu halten auch wenn sie
jetzt nicht mehr im
Infektionsschutzgesetz steht und nicht
mehr maßgeblich sein soll für viele
Bereiche des Alltags aber hier wird sie
ganz klar als Begründung angeführt dafür
dass es wieder Einschränkungen geben
kann und das während Länder auch unsere
Nachbarländer beispielsweise wie
Dänemark komplett lockern die schaffen
alles ab bei denen das wieder alles
stattfinden und wir sprechen gerade
jetzt im zweiten Corona Herbst schon
wieder von Einschränkungen und von
Messer Ausfällen jetzt hat Thomas ja
auch gerade gesagt das ist ja so ein
bisschen versteckt das ist ja versteckt
in wir brauchen zusätzliche Mittel dann
denkt natürlich erstmal jeder super ist
erstmal eine gute Idee zusätzliche
Mittel immer gut dann kam aber kommt der
Grund was meinst du was hat das jetzt
für Folgen wer redet da denn auch mal
Klartext wie dieser Winter und Herbst
jeder spricht von der vierten Welle für
uns alle ja vonstatten gehen soll also
was bitte was passiert mit den Schulen
jetzt geht es nur um Veranstaltungen ich
muss sagen bei mir gehen alle
Alarmglocken schon wieder an weil ich
denke okay wir werden also vielleicht
auch noch weitere Zettel bekommen auf
denen steht wir brauchen zusätzliche
Mittel denn und dann kommt eigentlich
der eigentliche Hammer absolut also man
sagt ja immer corona-krise da verändert
sich alles am laufenden Band man kann
nicht wirklich langfristig planen aber
ehrlich gesagt könnte man manche Dinge
einfach ausschließen gerade das was
entspricht Schulschließung man könnte
einfach sagen es ist unsere politische
Entscheidung wir machen Schulen nicht
mehr dicht egal auch mehr oder weniger
alle angekündigt alle haben die machen
das immer mit so einem Trick die sagen
immer Schulen dürfen nicht wieder
geschlossen werden ja dann gibt uns doch
die Garantie dass keine Schule mehr
geschlossen wird andere Länder haben das
gemacht noch bevor überhaupt geimpft
wurde in vielen anderen Ländern gab es
nie Schulschließungen während
Deutschlands Kinder zu Hause sitzen
mussten und das gilt ehrlich gesagt für
sehr viele Maßnahmen es ist das diese
corona-maßnahmen die waren nie ein
Naturgesetz und die sind auch jetzt kein
Naturgesetz es ist nicht so dass nur
wenn Inzidenzen steigen man Maßnahmen
einführen muss Maßnahmen Fängen muss das
öffentliche Leben Einschränkungen muss
um darauf zu reagieren ist auch nicht
nachgewiesen dass viele dieser Maßnahmen
irgendein Effekt hatten ganz oft hat man
im Nachhinein bemerkt hoppala die Zahlen
die Infektionszahlen wenn auch ohne
Maßnahmen gesunken einfach weil es
beispielsweise wärmer wurde kurze
Erinnerung
Finanzministerium wird geleitet von
Olaf Scholz richtig ich fand es
erstaunlich dass die corona-politik im
Wahlkampf überhaupt gar keine
überragende Rolle spielt wie man ja
annehmen könnte vielleicht weil die
Menschen glauben dass schlimmste ist
schon hinter uns und wir schauen nach
vorne sowohl in den triellen oder
sonstigen Diskussionen überhaupt nicht
das Thema Nummer eins obwohl es uns nach
wie vor beschäftigt ja das interessante
beim corona-wahlkampf ist ja die
Bundesregierung hat uns lange erzählt
die Menschen finden die Einschränkungen
super je härter der Kurs desto besser
und jetzt haben wir einen Wahlkampf
erlebt in dem alle versucht haben
auszuschließen dass es irgendwie wieder
zu einem Lockdown kommen wird eigentlich
müsst ihr die Logik hier sein wenn die
Menschen Einschränkungen so toll finden
dann müsste man den ein Lockdown
versprechen um gewählt zu werden jetzt
versucht man Corona schön fernzuhalten
und auch warum Corona im Wahlkampf kaum
mehr
also und ehrlich gesagt ein Grund warum
Corona im kanzlerwahlkampf auch keine
Rolle spielt ist dass sich die SPD und
die Union in viel wenig sind auch wenn
man in dieses Papier schaut dass wir
hier aus dem Finanzministerium haben das
von SPD-Kanzlerkandidat Scholz geführt
wird der Mehrbedarf also die
finanziellen Mittel die 150 Millionen
die wurden ja angemeldet vom
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium von Peter
Altmaier einem CDU-Minister einem ganz
eng vertrauten der Bundeskanzlerin also
er sieht auch schon dass Messen und
Veranstaltungen abgesagt wegen werden
könnten wegen Corona und meldet bei
Scholz an dass er 150 Millionen mehr
Steuergeld braucht also Union und SPD
Arbeiten beim Thema Corona wirklich Hand
in Hand da ist man sich eigentlich ein
fast alle meine ich
noch nie gehört
[Musik]